[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOE KAVA: Good
evening, everyone.
This is the die-hard
group staying
to the last session of the day,
even during happy hour, wow.
I feel like we should be
at Google, back during one
of our TGIF meetings.
We can all crack open a drink
and just sit here and chat.
So anyhow, thank you
very much for joining
our session this evening.
My name is Joe Kava, and I'm the
vice president of data centers.
So that means that I lead
the teams the design,
build, and operate our
data centers globally.
And I really appreciate your
interest in this topic today.
So I'm going to share with you
a little bit about what makes
Google data centers so unique.
So let's first start by
considering what do you
need from your data center.
Right.
Sorry, we're going
to go to plan B. See,
as a good data center guy,
I've always got a backup plan.
Anyhow, so whether
you're currently
in your own
enterprise data center
or you're in a multi-tenant
colocation facility, what
you need is access to high
performance computing,
always available around the
world, when you need it,
where you need it.
That's exactly what you get.
I know that-- as I
mentioned, you need access
to high performance computing
available around the world,
in highly available and
secure data centers.
Well, with Google Cloud
that's exactly what you get.
You get it where, when,
and how you need it.
We've been leaders in developing
ultra-high performance reliable
compute systems since the
earliest days at Google
and using the most
innovative designs.
And no matter how good our
teams and our systems perform,
we always feel that
we can do better.
So we have a relentless
focus on innovation.
And our high
performance computing
is the result of optimizing
throughout the entire stack.
Nearly all of our
infrastructure is
custom designed
and purpose-built
for our own computing needs,
from our own dedicated
high-voltage substations,
to our customized electrical
distribution systems, to
our cooling systems designed
and built purposely just
for our data centers,
all working in
conjunction and optimized
to provide the highest
performance and lowest
total cost of ownership
computing anywhere.
You know, when I first
joined Google nine years ago,
I was amazed at the
extraordinary lengths
that the company went to
build our own systems.
And of course, as
I learned more,
it became obvious
why we do that.
But at the time I
thought to myself--
I'm like, what
makes us so unique,
why don't we just buy
servers like everyone else?
Well, we go through all
the extraordinary effort
because, frankly, what
we needed at our scale
didn't exist when we started.
In order to achieve the
performance, efficiency
and price targets, we had
to build our own servers.
We had to develop and create
the hardware, and the software,
and the culture of reliability
to make Google successful.
Our servers don't include
any unnecessary components,
such as video cards, chipsets
or peripheral connectors,
which can introduce
vulnerabilities.
Our production servers
run a custom designed
and stripped-down version of
Linux that's been hardened,
and our servers
and their OSes are
designed for the sole purpose of
powering Google services only.
Our server resources are
provisioned dynamically.
They are allocated and allow
for us to be flexible in growth.
And they can be reprovisioned
quickly and efficiently,
adding capacity where it's
needed, when it's needed,
to quickly respond
to customer demand.
And recently we've
also contributed
our learning and our experience
with our custom 48 volt rack
systems.
We've contributed that design
to the Open Compute program,
so now Open Compute
program racks also work
in Google data centers.
And you know, since
I've been at Google,
we've fundamentally
redesigned our cooling systems
about every 12 to 18 months.
And along the way we've
pioneered and developed
advancements in water-based
cooling systems,
such as seawater cooling,
recycled gray water cooling,
storm water capture and
reuse, rainwater harvesting,
industrial canal water use
and thermal energy storage.
And we've also
designed data centers
that don't require any water
for the cooling at all.
Instead, they're cooled with
a 100% outside fresh air.
The point is that there is no
one-size-fits-all model here.
All of our data
center designs are
custom for that specific
region, that specific location,
to get the best efficiency.
We also invest a lot in robotic
innovation in our data centers.
Each of our data centers has
fully automated disk erase
environments.
This allows for faster,
higher throughput,
more efficient and better
inventory management.
Now, of course, along with
performance and innovation
you need data centers in
locations that work for you.
And at Google, our numerous
locations and fiber network
differentiates us from the rest.
Our IP network consists of
our own fiber, public fiber
and undersea cables.
And this allows us to deliver
highly available and low
latency services
across the globe.
But it also means that we
can respond faster to demand,
efficiently scaling our
capacity for when you need it
and where you need it.
It's even been noted by
several industry publications
that this is clearly
a standout for Google.
And of course, as
you can imagine
with the explosive growth
in public cloud computing,
we've had some pretty aggressive
expansion going on ourselves.
And of course,
our global network
brings our data centers close
together and closer to you.
We're available currently
in six regions and 18 zones
with over a 100
points of presence.
And our data
network is comprised
of hundreds of thousands of
miles of fiber optic cable.
To ensure every customer has
a cloud region near them,
Google Cloud will add
several more regions in 2017,
including the ones
that were announced
just this morning by orders.
So we now have new regions
available in the Netherlands,
Canada and California.
We need to operate our own
data centers around the world
to keep our own
products running 24x7.
Our data centers are part of a
very robust infrastructure that
supports Google scale and
Google's global network,
including our four
owned undersea cables,
just far more than any
other cloud provider has,
and our Edge points
of presence where
we connect Google's network
to the rest of the internet.
You know, we're
peering, of course.
And having those multiple points
of presence across the globe
provides strong
redundancy, so your data
is securely mirrored
across storage devices
in multiple locations.
By choosing Google
Cloud you can build
on the same future-proof
infrastructure
that Google builds on, the same
infrastructure that Google uses
to return billions
of search results
in milliseconds, the
same infrastructure
that Google uses to serve over 1
billion hours of YouTube a day,
the same infrastructure
that Google serves over 1
billion Gmail users every day.
And at the core of
our program really
is our commitment
to availability.
You know I've been doing
this a very long time,
and I've evaluated
dozens, if not hundreds,
of public and private data
centers all over the world.
And I can tell you that they're
not all created equally.
But when we say, it's really
7x24, we really mean it.
Our designs are fault-tolerant,
and this protects you
against potential failures.
And our critical infrastructure
is concurrently maintainable.
This means that whenever
something breaks or maintenance
is needed, we don't have to
take down services to do that.
There's no such thing
as scheduled outages
on Google Cloud.
This is invisible to
you and it enables
us to do all of this live.
We design our data centers
with an eye towards the future.
So we build in
"hooks" that allow
us to take advantage
and upgrade our systems
and network with the latest
platforms developments.
But we also staff
our data centers 24/7
with our own team
of Googlers who
have been intimately
designed from design--
or they've been intimately
involved from the design,
through construction
and commissioning,
and through operations.
They're the best
and the brightest
engineers and
operations professionals
available anywhere.
But they all come from
very diverse backgrounds
and they have one common
trait, all of them--
they're systems level thinkers.
Many of them have come from
mission critical environments,
like the Navy nuclear
submarine program, where
mistakes can be catastrophic.
They understand mission
critical operations.
Further, we've built site teams
at all of our data centers
that are comprised
of the engineers
responsible for the
design and construction
of the data center,
working side by side
with the operations teams.
Their experience and
qualifications is unmatched.
The majority of our staff
hold advanced degrees
in professional licensing.
They've been published in
technical papers and books,
and they hold patents
relevant to the industry.
And together these
integrated teams
are responsible for the capacity
commissioning and providing
7x24 operations.
This really gives us
an unparalleled level
of end-to-end ownership
of our infrastructure.
Having Googlers operate our
own data centers is really key.
You see, the norm
in the industry
is for the
design-build contractor
to hand over a set of
documents, drawings and manuals,
and the keys to the front
door, and wish the data center
operator good luck.
And all too often
the operations teams
aren't even employed by the
owner of that data center,
they're actually employed by the
lowest cost outsource bidder.
So the level of ownership
is maybe not quite
what we believe it should be.
And if there's one certainty
in mission critical operations,
it's that faults
and errors are going
to happen in the
middle of the night,
typically on a weekend, when
no one else is around to help
and all your
suppliers are closed.
But that's not the case at
Google, because it's us,
we're there 24/7.
All of our teams are
working around the clock
to provide the most available
compute infrastructure.
But you know,
equally as important
as the operational
excellence is transparency.
And really we want to have
the continual learning,
that when an issue does arise,
that we can expose that issue
and sent it around the
world to all of our teams
so that everyone
can learn from it.
We studied the root causes
of errors and issues
in the industry based
on published data.
And on the infrastructure
side, the industry norm
is that human error accounts
for the overwhelming majority
of all incidents.
However, because of our
designs and, frankly, because
of our very highly
qualified people,
only a small fraction
of our issues
are related to human errors.
And of those, none of them
has ever caused any downtime
at our data centers.
So in addition to high
performance, innovation
and availability, you
want your data center
to be environmentally
sustainable as well as secure.
So first let me talk about
sustainability a little bit.
Google data centers are the most
efficient and environmentally
friendly in the world.
For as long as I've been
building and operating data
centers, I've been an
advocate for efficiency
and sustainability.
Running our business in
environmentally responsible way
is important to us, and
it's something that we also
know it's important to you.
It takes a tremendous amount
of power to run at our scale.
As a matter of fact, last
year, the total amount
of energy consumed in
Google worldwide for all
of our operations was
just almost equivalent
to the total amount
of energy consumed
by the city of San
Francisco in the same year.
But we want to be really good
stewards to the environment,
even though we are
consuming a lot of power.
We want to use renewable
energy as much as possible.
So this year we're
very, very excited
to announce that
in 2017 Google is
going to reach a 100%
renewable energy for all
of our global operations, data
centers and offices combined.
This means that for the
calendar year in 2017 Google
is directly purchasing enough
wind and solar electricity
to account for every
unit of electricity
we consume globally.
This is a huge milestone
for us, and it's, frankly,
the culmination of
seven years of effort
from all of my colleagues
across the company.
So how did we get here?
We started this
journey back in 2010
when we did our first wind
deal with a wind farm in Iowa.
Back then we were amongst
the first corporations
to go out and buy
renewable energy directly.
We then started expanding,
doing more deals globally
and moving more into
solar along the way also.
We now have 20 deals that
are equivalent to 2.6
gigawatts of renewable energy.
And this has generated
emissions reductions
that are equivalent to taking
1.2 million cars off the road.
And in doing so this makes us
the largest corporate buyer
of renewable energy in the
world, and by a wide margin.
And thanks in part to the work
of renewable energy tariffs,
and our power
purchase agreements,
and the related efforts by
our peers in the industry,
the number of corporate
renewable energy deals
is soaring.
We've been committed
to sustainability
since the earliest days of
our data center program,
and we've been carbon neutral
for more than 10 years now.
And in addition, we had a number
of accolades along the way,
awards and high marks.
Most recently, Google
achieved the final grade of A
in Greenpeace's
2017 Clicking Clean
report which benchmarks the
energy performance of the IT
sector.
And only three companies out
of the 15 that they evaluated
achieved that A grade.
So it's something
we're very proud of.
We're very excited by the
growth in renewable energy,
and we're dedicated
to increasing
the ability of customers to take
control of their energy supply.
But there is more
work to be done.
We continue to look for new
ways to help utility business
models become more
customer-centric,
so that cost effective
renewable energy
is available to
anyone who wants it.
And finally, security is
of the utmost importance
in our data centers.
Our infrastructure is protected
by more than 800 top experts
in information, application
and network security.
And Google's focus on
security and data protection
is amongst our primary
design criteria.
Our physical security team or
our physical security systems
feature a layered
security model,
including safeguards like custom
designed electronic access
cards, alarms, vehicle access
barriers, perimeter fencing,
metal detectors,
biometric authentication.
And our data center floors
are protected by a laser beam
intrusion detection.
Our data centers
are monitored 24/7
by high resolution interior
and exterior cameras that
can detect and track intruders.
Access logs, activity
records and camera footage
are available in case
any incident does occur.
And our data centers are
also routinely patrolled
by very experienced
security guards
who have undergone rigorous
background checks and training.
And you know, the closer you
get to the data center floor,
the more rigorous the
security systems get also.
As a matter of fact, to gain
access to the data center
floor, it's only available
through a secure corridor that
requires badge access, biometric
authentication and passing
through anti-tailgate devices.
And only approved
employees that have
a specific role to beyond
the center floor ever set
foot there.
That means that less than 1%
of our employee population
ever set foot in one of
our own data centers.
We employ a very
strict end-to-end chain
of physical custody for storage,
tracking everything from cradle
to grave, from the first time
a hard disk goes into a machine
until it's verified,
cleaned and erased.
We know everything
about that media--
we know who touches it,
when it was touched,
what it was touched
for and why, what's
its next expected action.
Our information security
and physical security
go hand in hand.
As you know, data
is most vulnerable
when it's in transit, and
for this reason securing
data in transit is our
highest priority at Google.
Data traveling between customers
devices and our data centers
is encrypted using HTTPS/TLS,
so Transport Layer Security.
And in fact, Google was the
first major cloud provider
to enable TLS encryption.
And this homogeneous
environment is
maintained by proprietary
software that continually
monitors the systems binaries
for any binary modifications.
For our teams to
be successful, they
must have advanced
real time visibility
into the status
and functionality
of our infrastructure.
As you know, to say that
Google is obsessed with data
might be a little bit
of an understatement.
So our teams build systems that
allow us to monitor everything.
We've built world class
monitoring and control systems
for all functional areas--
from the servers, and
storage, and network,
to the electrical distribution,
the mechanical cooling systems,
and the security systems.
We're monitoring all aspects
of performance and operations
from chip to chiller.
And as I've mentioned,
energy efficiency
is at the heart of our
sustainability program.
We believe that the best
energy saved is the energy not
consumed in the first place.
That's why we pioneered
hyperefficient computing
systems and data centers.
And that's why our data centers
consume, on average, only half
of the energy of a typical
enterprise data center.
What makes us really
stand out in this regard,
is how we've applied
machine learning
to drive energy
efficiency even further.
If you've been in
the keynote speeches
over the last couple
of days, you've
heard how much emphasis Google
has been placing on our machine
learning programs.
Well, you can imagine
our data centers are
very large and complex,
where the electrical
and mechanical control systems
are all working together
to deliver optimal performance.
But because of the sheer
number of interactions
and possible settings
for all of these systems,
it's impossible
for us mere mortals
to visualize what the
best ways to set up
the data center controls are
for those specific operating
conditions, and to
do it in real time.
However, really, it's fairly
trivial for the computers
to crunch through all of
these possible scenarios
and find the optimal settings.
So over the past
couple of years,
we've developed an
algorithm, and we've
trained it with
billions of data points
from all of our data
centers all over the world.
We now use machine
learning models
to help visualize the status so
the operations teams can set up
the data center electrical
and cooling plants
for the most optimal efficient
performance on any given day.
It's also used considering up
to 19 independent variables
like the weather outside, the
temperature, the humidity,
the wind direction,
the wind speed.
All of these things go into how
efficient a data center runs.
But without a machine
learning model
it's almost impossible
for the operations teams
to try and adjust
that in real time.
So, in partnership with
our colleagues at DeepMind,
our data center
team built models
to recognize and learn
from these patterns
in the large amounts
of operational data
that we collect
every day anyhow.
We just were storing it and
not really using it that well.
So now, over some trial and
error and perfecting the model,
the model is now over 99.6%
accurate in predicting our PUE.
And PUE is Power
Usage Effectiveness,
it's a measure of data
center efficiency.
And it has helped us to identify
up to 40% savings in the data
center cooling overhead.
This equates to an overall
15% reduction in our PUE,
which may not seem
like a lot, but if you
think about the hundreds
of megawatts of data center
capacity that we have
online every year,
that is equated to several
tens of millions of dollars
in energy savings per year.
But you might wonder,
why do I care?
Why do I care if your data
centers are efficient?
Well, one of the
reasons why you care
is because our operating
costs are directly related
to the efficiency
of our data centers.
Our pricing on Google
Cloud is directly related
to our operating costs.
So the more efficient
we are internally,
the more of that savings
we can pass through to you,
and we can offer the most high
performance lowest costs public
cloud available.
And leveraging our strength
in this machine learning,
we've succeeded in increasing
the overall efficiency
of our data center fleet.
This makes Google the
data center you need,
the one that you really
can't afford to be without--
high performance computing,
available around the world,
secure, reliable, where you
need it, when you need it
and how you need it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]